this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
got the Great
you got a great voice
I know it's bro I don't know baby but
I'm not gonna fight around the kid yeah
damn that gets me fired up why can't
that be our intro music let's go The
Spider and the kid it's from [__]
copying uh Iron Maiden I guess in my
bedroom as a kid bro that's what we I
want to use that as our intro just just
that the power and the kid the fighter
and the kids yeah it's really uh 80s
yeah ah it's good man he's bringing it
back wrestling room rat first rat album
oh yeah out on the streets that's where
we meet
did you ever see the Iron Maiden that
the um Court uh the sort of like court
case and they asked the lead singer
because this guy this he they were being
sued because this kid committed suicide
listening to the song and he they asked
himself I don't know but they asked him
to sing the song the rhyme of the
Ancient Mariner he actually sang it
acabella he's like hey
what is the thing you do at the end
and he's like what and he goes the thing
you're like meh like that and he goes
that sounds just how I breathe my next
person so awkward the number of the
Beast the sacrifice going on tonight but
they didn't actually say they got away
with it right Jake and actually said
yeah yeah I mean it's like we wrote a
song dude I mean what do you want me to
do how are you going to sue me for well
remember they tried blaming uh Marilyn
Manson on the combine stuff remember
that they said well they said Marilyn
Manson what would you have said to the
those kids the combine Shooters and he
said I wouldn't have said anything I
would have listened and that's no one
ever oh that's not powerful then they
talk for 11 minutes you're like I've
heard enough yeah oh by the way you guys
are crazy the one guy was Associated
crazy even though he was a psychopath he
had a history of uh psychotic behavior
oh yeah there's animals
they tried going after the parents like
where were you you got a hundred
squirrels in the [__] basement dead
and done yeah well figure it out one kid
was so depressed apparently that he got
manipulated by the psychopath the
psychopath was the one who really
orchestrated it
as Colin Quinn would say all right
because it takes all kinds you know
you know what the fly said when he
walked over the mirror it's one way of
looking at it you know
anyway gang it's good to see Brandon
again
uh so
I had so much fun last time and you guys
uh George and Chin do a good job of uh
like editing the clips and everything it
made it really much easier for me to
Georgie does all the Georgie does it all
and uh but then I'm like you know I post
it co-post it we collaborate then I'm
reading the comments I was like do your
fans like you oh us oh my God yeah like
it's I was like oh I remember this world
well those aren't fans you know those
are they're listening well exactly
they're listeners you specifically I'm
like what Brandon does is [__] try to
help others and mind his own business
but they don't know that yeah they just
they well then they do though cocky
football player and that's that's how
they I don't think that's it I think
football player well you mean when I
stop playing 20 years ago back in the
day yeah
I do think that if people saw the [__]
you do behind the scenes they'd be like
oh I don't think it'd matter no no they
wouldn't care no those people you can't
win some people just some people hate
you for now you know what you know what
Reggie Jackson said fans don't boo
nobodies
he also said when uh he hit his third
home run in the World Series a Reporter
Goes what were you thinking as you
rounded the bases he goes the magnitude
of me
who's better but he's it's true I know
like three [__] you just hit three
home runs in the World Series he was
rounding second like God damn I'm a
[__] Chief the worst thing you
could do if you're really famous is read
comments like like these you know any of
these athletes I see are these like you
could still read them yeah I mean I
don't I never have I never had that
level I think you have to get the
certainly you don't read them well I I
never have come on because I think you
know who does is Kevin Durant he's a
[__] he's a beast God damn he's got
thin skin there was a Twitter chat is it
called Twitter chat Twitter Twitter
where you do a group chat oh yeah yeah
and the name of the group was Kevin
Durant is not top five any
like dude all I know about you is you
are top five oh and every time you do
this it makes me just think you're an
idiot it's pretty cool I don't like to
do that like some people like to engage
with it and it's it's their Pastime I I
don't think it's healthy either way well
I learned it gets to him but I think the
good yeah the good and the bad are both
destructive in a way because the Good
Will Will Define you and you'll start
aiming for it so I I think it's a I
think it's poison all the way around but
also my heroes growing up whether it was
in stand-up or in uh Athletics they
didn't even have the option who were
Your Heroes growing up what's your bag
what's your bag
oh man Jim Carrey Adam Sandler Junior
saying yeah
[Music]
I like that he takes care of his boys
he's super loyal yeah he forces Netflix
when he signs those deals he's like I'll
do it but I'm using my crew and like
whatever man if the world I was on Earth
who are your favorites who do you look
up Carlin yeah me too oh my God that's
hell
anybody with Al in their last name
Adele Adele how good does it tell how
good is [__] David tell he's I had a
guy call me yesterday and I answered the
phone guess who's not crying and he knew
exactly what I was saying like he goes
you know that a Talbot don't you wish
you could have sex with the first person
you ever had sex with again just to show
him how good you got at it hey look
who's not crying like a big boy
he's the best you know the Farley story
with me and him no
me and David teller in our office it's
like two in the morning we're smoke
we're not doing any work we don't tell
what that's on our life yeah we showed
it off I didn't know that and we're like
we're smoking cigarettes and like
flicking each other in the dick guy
stuff yeah guy stuff and Farley walks in
it's like 2 A.M and just Farley [__]
Farley walks in he's like what are you
guys doing
and at the same time we both said we'll
pay you a hundred dollars to take a [__]
out the window
be twins like we looked at each other
what are the odds that we said that
exact sentence we'll pay 100 take a [__]
out the window and Farley goes give me
the money first
so we're just like putting money on the
so it's like coins and dollar bills and
he puts the money in his pocket then he
like lifts up the desk
Farley was Herculean strong yeah he
lifts the desk up and the coins like in
a cartoon slide down the desk into his
pocket like it was crazy and he goes out
on the window and puts the window this
is the 17th floor and he puts the window
on the back of his neck and he's just he
just starts grinding like and it was
obvious like right away that Chris
Farley did not have to [__] at all
because he was like purple like he was
going like and it's Farley so he's like
and after like two minutes this little
like big Newton without any Newton
dropped out of Chris's ass and goes in
the window onto my desk
I remember just sitting there like
Showbiz right
Showbiz this is you wanted to make it
kid this is this is it yeah
was a writer I'm sorry life yeah I had
no idea he's so brilliant he's so like
look who's not crying so like a big boy
something about mace that really bothers
my eyes
it makes me lose my erection do you have
a do you have like a holy [__] I'm gonna
show business moment because I got one
better than that
um
I really I'm not really listening to
yours I'm just please set it up so yeah
give me yours give me yours set it up
anyway
s Behavior you know am I
who's yours what do you got okay you've
had some big moments when I did the
Paris Theater in Vegas when I went to
get paid the guy was writing me my check
and they had a dry erase board of all
the acts that month and I was between
Chaka Khan and Tony Bennett
hey everybody damn I heard Jay Moss
coming you missed the Saturday dance
he's funny now okay hi Brandon
oh you know the Virginia basketball
coach is named Tony Bennett no the
college basketball coach yeah he's great
coach and one year during the uh NCAA
tournament he had a heart attack and he
took a knee on the court and so Twitter
was was [__] like a like just
trending Tony Bennett heart attack Tony
Bennett Tony Bennett Tony Bennett the
singer
who's like at 80 and getting a little
you know hmm he tweets everybody I'm out
there as a horse don't believe what you
hear
it's like
that's like 30 000 retweets because it's
just so funny like nobody's talking
about there's another Tony Bennett don't
worry about that guy four days later he
tweet when Frank Sinatra Jr dies
when Frank Sinatra Jr died his next
tweet like four days later as my heart
goes out to the Sinatra family and the
death of Frank Jr like 11 retweens
hey everybody I'm fine
hey box out now
because doing Tony Bennett doing stuff
with Lady Gaga yeah they did the duet
his voice his voice is just unbelievable
still at 90. yeah it was it
does that match it wasn't bad but then
when it was next to Lady Gaga he was
like a Powerhouse have you heard them
sing together it's interesting really I
mean it's a it's a good dance yeah they
get like dude it was kind of like the
talk thing yeah he's like get it here
honey let me put a nickel in the machine
nickel oh my God
and she's just hitting the notes he's
like yeah there it is she's a good
actress Amy Winehouse just trying to
sing uh with him with him how's she
doing and she's there so so you didn't
hear but um bring up the article on her
uh Tony Bennett no she just couldn't uh
she kept quitting she kept stopping I'm
not good no no she was so nervous but
they they killed it yeah yeah yeah they
did well
yeah he said he said he was sorry he
didn't tell her how important she was
Tony Bennett really killed Amy Winehouse
right by not saying that yeah he's the
reason yeah you were in Denver you did
all the morning shows yeah I did yeah
the best right yeah Lewis and Kathy uh
they're great and uh it's just good
people man I love those those uh Rick
Lewis's Rick Lewis is a solid guy like
they'll have you on they'll stretch the
clock he's like a guy's guy like a boxer
yeah he's like he like takes fights like
he's a fox yeah I never talked to him
about that he doesn't like you what he's
a big character he's a big guy he's a
big sort of talk but uh Matt mcchesney
is is uh I was watching videos yeah he
teaches college and high school kids and
yeah to get him ready for college and he
gets him ready like it's like he's
intense teaches him what football oh get
the get your [__] get your [__]
arm down there lay some pants on
somebody guys this is you know I uh when
you know this like because I was at a
show business for a couple years
sure you look at my IMDb page it goes
from like
movies with Forest Whitaker and Al
Pacino and then all of a sudden it's
like nothing nothing talking dog movie
I did one of those but I'm not a lead
dog I'm like a Salesman a chewy baton I
work at bark Williams
so I was out it's one of my point when I
came when I came back into stand up
after like rehab and all that
maybe not such great cities like that I
wasn't thrilled about it's pretty
humbling but uh we're like the First
shows at 6 p.m yeah 5 30 p.m people are
eating salads kill myself I wanna I
wanna kill myself though you do the more
I did a Morning Show and uh I did the TV
gets dicey and I did uh I think it was
Grand Rapids I did the morning good
morning Grand Rapids and I went on after
a blind girl hit a free throw and then
somebody with a big long stick so
somebody had a big long stick and
they're tapping the backboard so she
could like hone in on it
I missed the old days when you just had
to follow somebody making an omelette
all those morning TV shows like the
[__] three points when you do some of
those morning TV shows like how are you
guys keeping the lights on like you look
around you're like who's watching how do
you do it in the first place like that's
also but they're the same everywhere he
goes like hey I'm sitting here with Jay
Moore how you feeling man it's like the
guy from the weather guy just walks over
from the green screen and goes okay
ready
or they've done no research like uh we
had we got Jay Moore uh Jerry Maguire
that must have been fun huh y'all any
pranks on set
what are the pranks like
well one time I took a [__] in Tom
Cruise's mouth the cubic good and Junior
ever grab you you know it's like I heard
he's actually Dominican are there any
rumors did you get to know Tom Cruise at
all or no he was great it was great
right
that [__] wattage yeah he he uh my
dad said to me
Tom Cruise is the greatest like man
you'll ever meet in your life he's like
Dale Carnegie like it's nuts and my dad
goes my dad raced in the same race as
Tom Cruise oh yeah he told us this and
then when you saw me
thank God I was trying to help thank you
yeah thank you like the comments before
I only have like 14 stories
just get super quiet by the way I got
caught in a hail storm for uh it was bad
out there in Denver I couldn't be but by
the way we ran out of stuff talking
about no I couldn't move something no I
was just thinking about this weather no
I was thinking about this because I like
your car gets destroyed I didn't know
that in Denver yeah but that's insane
I'm driving back I mean what I call this
the sin of banality yeah well that's
true but I mean when you're when your
windows get like this big when your
windows okay a tornado they had hailed
he's got a convertible yeah anyways a
tree fell in their house
would you drive to Denver well I drove
back from the airport and started
raining and all of a sudden I swear to
God the car started going boom boom and
the guy was just gonna [__] my car up
and I'm like are you kidding me right
now and then uh you you get caught out
there like a bunch of people got killed
didn't they and and uh
how many people you'll be especially
injured you gotta be a special lady to
get killed a bunch of people there at a
concert like hail yes like I mean I've
been hit with like golf ball size hail
and it [__] hurts but for it to kill
you gotta be a real [__]
list of costly or Colorado amplitude
this one right there injure is nearly a
hundred look at that uh well it's
injure's 100 yeah injured because when
they're big like that yeah I don't think
it was probably more from getting
trampled as people were running no
nobody died Brian I know you want
someone to die there uh three people
died in Texas
tennis ball sized hail storms oh that's
so serious it hurts it blows out your
Willie B was saying his car was out
there and uh all the windows got yeah I
mean it's rare it happens like that but
it happened when I was in college but
yeah you get kind of that Hill I mean it
[__] hurts it feels like just you
know BB guns yeah
how's the weather where you're at okay
folding rectangle hey only three people
have didn't know has been killed by
hailstones so if you get killed by hail
you're an [__]
that's what I'm saying you'll be real I
mean in 1930 a baby babies are really
easy to kill it's terrible unfortunately
I mean if you're like old in a
wheelchair you just get stuck after I
can see it lighten you up but it's gonna
happen eventually just oh just grab your
jack and put it over your head that's
fine yeah it says they're the highest uh
hailstorm death year on record was 1888.
holy [__] all right well that's great
that's like that's like um
you [__] go to Florida and we go to
the store you guys want anything
yeah your energy was good today because
uh the Lakers signed the great white
hype or boy Reeves Austin Reeves excuse
me pretending I know yeah he doesn't
know he doesn't fall back we're gonna
sign him awesome he's the white dude on
the Lakers like the only white dude he's
a ball in the playoffs he's a ball
that's all Brian needs to know yeah a
white guy
how to buy his jersey now I'm an athlete
guys baller but I thought I thought he
was gonna leave because you see some of
the contracts that they're offering no
because they had the right to match it
was restriction I know I'm just saying
don't get me wrong he's a baller but
you're not gonna pay him 120 million
yeah you know like some of these guys
they would have paid him whatever it was
oh man whatever it was they would
imagine it would match it because he's
just he's a generational Talent or at
least a generational like
yeah like box office Talent like people
love watching this guy play really it's
just a [__] grinder
he's a scrappy [__] what is he yeah
and he's he always gets contact he's
always at the street and he had like
it's when you make the threes too like
if your three percentage is good that's
great but if you're making threes again
in a playoff game and it's from half
court at the buzzer to put you up 11.
it's like damn I love this guy yeah yeah
he was over so his mom sat right behind
me at one of the playoff games and I was
like why does he keep looking I didn't
realize it but I'm like why is he keep
looking over here so after he made a big
play he looked over at his mom
oh and I was like this is like I just
wanna like that's all any of us it'll
everything that's wrong with us are good
with us it all goes back to the living
room as a kid I just want you to look at
me that's why I'm doing that's why I'm
dancing in front of the TV that's
exactly right and like he'd hit a three
and he'd be like going to the free free
throw line he's like
he's on Mom one time we're at a Lakers
game and my son
like so he gets he's like two years he
was ten and Rajon Rondo
who looks kind of like a gargoyle anyway
yeah he just keeps looking at my son
going
like doing gang signs and my son starts
crying like what is wrong no keep
looking at me and we're all like I don't
know like Rajon Rondo's like really mad
dog and my son his parents were sitting
right behind his whole there was like 11
Rondo like three roads behind me
he looks like he should be outside like
the Saint Regis in Manhattan about the
fourth floor looking down at traffic
wow he's a Celtic for a while he's a
good player
there he is with his head on crooked
what uh what position does the other guy
play Reeves is he guarding he's a guard
guard yeah
but where do you see the money some of
these free agents are getting here like
I guess that dude's worth 100 Mil three
year 100 Mil dude I remember getting
paid the nuts salary capsule like the
evolution why is that like well it's
like that
Levar lamello ball signed a deal
it was like three years I forget with
200 million four years 200 million but
they showed he'll make more in those
four years than Jordan made his entire
career now it's different like obviously
inflation stuff like that it's just that
there's more money in the game now but
it's also compared to that yeah but in
four years that's going to be a middle
of the pack contract correct because
that happened with uh Mike Conley when
he signed a massive contract with I
guess it was the Jazz I was like God how
do you pay that guy that much and like
three years go by and he's just in the
middle of the pack well that's like the
salary cap goes up that's like Stephen A
Smith when Pat McAfee signed with ESPN
recently and was like man he's making so
much more money than you and he's like
this is a good thing he's like this is
good this is great he goes I have he was
my contract to end up uh ends at the end
of this year now I know what I have you
know now I know no I know no I know yeah
I like how about ESPN lays off like 440
people but they gave this guy 110
million and he's getting so much why did
ESPN uh lay off all those people 21
people on air talent I don't know no
one's paying attention when when you go
woke yo bro is that what it is oh yeah
because because it started going away
from Sports and it's like all this weird
political stuff right they start diving
to that people ask lives matter people
stop watching I'm trying to see if the
Yankees beat the Red Sox why are you
well they did they did a post yeah they
did a poll on the the affirmative action
thing when the Supreme Court you know
overturned that the media is going crazy
right Michelle Obama and everybody but
the majority of Americans black brown
white asian all are against race-based
correct uh you know it's just
interesting and Brian's talked to them
all I have according to polls
but ESPN like they let go of like Jalen
Rose Mike Van Gundy like all these
people and it's like what are you gonna
do who's what yeah it doesn't matter
right who yeah yeah it's yeah yeah [__]
happens man you know what I mean it's
like yeah I'm with you like we've been
through the barrel we've gotten [__]
time out coming in now yeah it's like
what are you gonna do and at the end of
the day nobody cares no yeah but also
the next guy to jump on yeah we live in
a truly capitalistic market-driven
economy I'm talking about comics and
actors like there's nobody's nobody's
coming to help you there's no bailout
there's nothing it's either you or we'll
see you later but you got to put butts
in the seat or not and nobody can really
it's interesting like a lot of people
don't live that way it's where our whole
existence is subjective
our entire career is whether or not
other people like us and go
[__] like nobody has that like that like
these guys said it like they're funny
guys right but they just there's a task
they complete the task you go okay cool
like they know they completed the task
yeah like you know like if I'm a clerk I
put these things away and then I go over
here and then I write this report and
then I hand it to that guy that's just
how it's just a machine it's just a hive
that goes our whole thing is whether or
not strangers hundreds at a time are
like he was like euphoric and you have
to get their attention to begin with so
they come to see you right now that's
why I open with a joke always oh
I'm so [__] proud of that joke I'll
take it I'm so proud of that [__]
that [__] joke I just told but then
but then now as a comic or even in
podcasts like the like it's a deep pool
though I just compete with so much
garbage yeah it's garbage yeah but these
guys are great some of the garbage
people deal with you know and it's going
I I don't have resembler hate at anyone
like I'll see something like oh that's
insane every comic on Instagram is doing
crowd work yeah I'm like what what's
this is that your new stuff
so people copy it so Matt Rife is really
great at it no no no but people follow
that rifle is new you can't say that
Matt Rife just got it on as far as big
but he's got famous you guys say Matt
Rife it sounds like you're making fun of
Asians
I pronounce it in Mandarin not Rife
Schultz you've been doing for you for
years yeah but I'm saying that that's
like six months two Stark examples but
most you know and everybody copies that
but two people really made it work for
themselves has anybody ever like gotten
a deal doing crowd work uh
uh the answer is I believe no
fun deal
defined deal as far as selling that like
from Live Nation for touring yeah I know
it's people you don't get a deal to like
you get paid per touring but deals isn't
as in you know
I gotta get out of this [__] business
well if crowd work helps you all my
opening access all my opening acts are
selling out Arenas now yes whatever you
it's it's whatever get whatever it is it
doesn't matter I never been able to
really turn I'm in Appleton
yeah
not anymore not anymore yeah but then
then also you're fine yeah it's my back
club uh but then you're fighting the
Demon of YouTube too that Rogan called
it but it was just like when he went out
he said you guys need to get out it's
only gonna get worse I'm like I get that
but we're not YouTube so if we jump we
lose the fan base like we're not you
when you get out of what YouTube YouTube
because YouTube sensor like if we cuss
early on this this is suppressed so the
freedom of speech on YouTube is no
longer that like except for in the
comments he did yeah a lot of people get
like wait why why because they're
suppressing everything he'll talk about
who are you talking about are you Tim
Dylan okay Matt's I mean stuff because
of the way he talks about it they
suppress it well whatever if he cuss he
said something they don't like it's boom
well I don't think it's because Tim
Dillon doesn't like black people they
should take him up yeah yeah I think
that's uh it's a stretch I mean where's
his first amendment right now have you
heard of 85 South it's three Comics they
they tour together they do Arenas now
they're massive but early early on are
they three black guys yeah yes
DC Young Fly but what they did early on
is they said they would meet with
YouTube because one of their videos
would do whatever a million views next
one do 60 000 views or for three months
they would do like they would be getting
sixty thousand dollars a month the next
month they would get ten thousand
they're like oh you can't bet you can't
run a business like this right it's up
to their discretion no and you know how
it is like I argue with YouTube all the
time when you go to them they they don't
give you any explanation like no we just
don't agree with it yeah but tell us why
like nope sorry so they what they did is
built their own platform like really
we're out we're gonna get put a
highlight on YouTube and still have our
page but now everyone has to come over
here we're doing our stuff are they on
rumble or they're just Myspace
what are the guys names sound like you
were calling in an airstrike or
something 85 South yeah and what are the
guys names uh do you see young fly 85
South DC Young Fly
clear who else it's a joke
pbr3 Gang This is Mother Goose 85 South
DC Young Flyers all your remaining
Firepower within my compound
they're massive though massive that's
three guys DC young guy yeah did you use
did you what are their names I'm really
asking Carlos Miller Chico where the
[__] are your eyes Chico Bean
holy [__] yeah yeah you don't have them
it's in the Black Hole Sun video wow
yeah are you a demon demons yeah you
can't yeah you can't see are you guys
related no oh
it takes all kinds you know just being
observational guys DC young boy Young
Fly and fly Chico beans there's two DC's
no there's DC Young Fly Young Fly that's
one guy he's a young fly his wife just
passed his girlfriend just passed away
so there's DC Young Fly Chico Bean who's
like the brains of operation and Carlos
Miller yeah and Carlos Miller I need
three comments Carlos Miller needs a
cooler name you got a Chico Bean You're
Gonna Roll in you're gonna need a cool
name give me a cool name cross face
cross face cross face killer nearside
cradle yeah cross face I like Rings what
wrinkles rings for him yes Rings no but
I need to say fly Rings he's a good
clown name right Rings B let's take a
little break from chowing with our good
buddy Jay Moore one of the best dude I
should do it because we're here to talk
about nuts we love macadamia nuts how's
the macadamias how you get macadamia
nuts that don't break your bank they
they have they're not just for Jeff
Bezos they have the best macadamia nuts
on the market they come from South
Africa they work with farmers and
Macadamia Oil just so you know
is has even more monosaturated fat than
Olive Oil they've got rare omega-7 fatty
acids they are by many people's
standards the most healthy nut
definitely the best the most tasting
they're delicious and these white
chocolate flavored the dip Master oh my
God and they're not too much find a
better nut dude find them better they're
your own sugar and you don't even
realize it yep so you can just keep
eating and they're farmer owned that's
how they make it so cheap for you guys
so you don't have to be just the rich to
be eating macadamias in your mouth you
can eat like a like an aristocrat but
yeah yes hey absolutely how's the
academics range of products from hand
sorted nuts would save you all natural
flavors dipped in sugar-free chocolate I
like the the regular chocolate but these
are the white chocolate they get the
raspberry chocolate they got the hand
sword nuts they give them Macadamia bars
the creamy nut Butters they got extra
virgin Macadamia Oil yep what and
they're giving you guys a discount house
they never run discounts yeah dude very
special deal all right forth let's get
weird the limit time they're gifting you
a free box of 45 Macadamia snack bars
one of each flavor the variety pack when
you visit houseomeacademias.com tfak you
get 20 off your entire order plus the
snack bars variety pack that's how some
macadamias.com tfak we're back guys I
think we're too old for nicknames at
this point I think so too and that's
when you know we found the body so right
that's right and that was I remember
weeping over the holes
um I tooled to get a tattoo as well I
think there's nothing I would get hey
this might be a hot take but and I'm not
a Biden fan in any facet but hunter
Biden looks pretty fun to hang out with
he does I'm just gonna go on record this
guy looks like he's a blast back in the
day when I was wild yes it looks like
he'd been a good co-pilot yeah he uh
driving 100 miles an hour down Vegas
Highway oh wow on meth in a [__] crew
how do you [__] up that headline with a
photo of 172 circled in red and the head
wow though
and he's in a turbo Porsche going 100
safe miles an hour on math are you out
of your mind
and there's a hooker in the car I'm just
saying I don't condone what he's doing
but it seems like a fun time back in the
past that's that's interesting why not
condone it who gives a [__] yeah you're
right well because he'd kill other
people I guess driving okay look at him
he's all cracked out right there God
damn he's got baby shoes in his mouth
never hey never take the first White on
the color chart at the dentist office no
no you look like Audrina Partridge for
the rest of your life
like just move a couple down and get
like the offline it's too obvious yeah
right yeah that white that's two that's
but the stuff come back uh out on him is
not so then he gotta slap on the wrist
right yeah where most people go to wait
for like six years black went away for
three years yeah well even now but then
they leaked his uh WhatsApp text and now
he's kind of [__] what do you mean
because there's more stuff in that him
talking to the Chinese government
threatening for 10 million they deposit
the 10 million the bank account crack
don't pay for itself baby that boy is
wild he did some [__] hey this is the
other thing though like I can I'm kind
of understand some of it like let's say
but you know let's say you were like you
know a big time in the government you
would take care of your boys yeah you
know what I'm saying like I understand
Hunter Biden has no business being you
know the middleman with Ukraine and
China but it's your boy we gotta give
him a job we got bread well here's my
here's here's the the rub it's like so
you're the vice president son what your
Vice your dad has nothing to do he could
just be never talk to you what happens
is other those companies those [__]
companies from Ukraine China wherever
they might be they come to you they come
to you and they say we'd love to give
you a job we want to pay you a million
dollars great just sit on our board we
just want we just want you okay I accept
and you have no experience in the oil
business you're not going to say no
you're gonna go you want to fly me first
class to have a meeting and then just
put me on a payroll and you're 100
giving me 1.5 million absolutely okay
with bonuses if we do well so you're
you're gonna you're being you got he's
he's smoking right he's got hookers he's
getting paid his dad could have done
nothing and he but they obviously
obviously is a pay to play obviously
they wanted to say some things or at
least just get Biden's attention and
there's going to be corruption but will
the corruption too he's gonna do it yeah
but when it starts influencing the dad
tune the dad's receiving money as well
his dad in that situation would probably
his dad was smart to save himself a few
troubles his father would say don't do
this they're doing it because I'm but we
all know this
like the the Clinton this Clinton
Foundation the minute Hillary Clinton
lost the presidential uh election
all funding dried up nobody was giving
money to the foundation there's no
favorites at the beginning but why would
you so one of the biggest company
countries like Saudi Arabia were giving
no I know I'm saying but why if she lost
but it was obviously that proved that it
was a slush fund of course that proved
that it was all [__] [__] but
that's across the board how it goes so
what's the Hope like the the Chinese
oligarch the word oligarch I don't know
what it means what do you think the
Chinese oligarch yeah like their hope is
that Hunter Biden at Thanksgiving goes
dad you know what you should really talk
to uh duck son yes that is the case and
dad goes oh and he just goes into
[__] he goes down to the boat house
and goes ducks on yeah my son said
you're a nice guy yeah I just wanted to
know if like oh well no more more of
that if there's a contract
and they want you know to pass there's
political there could be a political
push or just a nod in that direction
that's a bunch of [__] Crooks all of
them you know I was listening I listened
to radio in the car all the time like I
like talk radio me too and I'll listen
to like the right wing talk radio there
isn't really a lot of left-wing well
maybe you'll let me know in the comments
uh but the right wing they're always go
like well people say Trump did this but
Biden did that earlier and he'll it's
like well then why isn't your show all
of these people suck yeah like why are
you picking a side on this one because
they play for that team if the whole
highway is [__] in need of repair
correct take your thoughts off the air
it's exactly right though that's that's
where that's where Washington becomes an
economy of influence so there's no
difference after all between Democrats
and Republicans it's just about being in
a position where you can help someone
out and that's when you know there's a
great book and he says there's one line
it he said you know you have a problem
you know you have a problem when good
people must behave corruptly to survive
and that's what you get in what book is
it though what book is going to say what
book it's called Republic loss by
Lawrence lessig and he's a
constitutional scholar out of it but the
cocktail says do people get the
government they deserve right yes but we
have lost he says we are losing our
Republic as long as you got major
problems for Americans and Congress is
spending most of their time doing what
arguing about swipe fees for banks
because that's who gets them elected and
if you're a congressman you spend 60 of
your time off campus meaning
I know I was trying to get us out our
boy uh Robert F Kennedy he had a lot of
momentum and boy you forget he's
Democrat boy did he [__] up he lost a
lot of the momentum because he's like
and also I want to take away guns
Americans went oh
well joint I sent you that article on
him I didn't read it no interesting I
saw who made it and I was like I'm gonna
pass you know what party uh I vote for
down ballot
block party
block party is what I'm talking about
bro remember whatever happened to block
parties when you're a kid they close up
the streets close off the street all the
adults are Day Drinking Your bouncy
house you you always have a grill does
that you have your really good uh jump
on your bicycle you jump your friends
kids would line up on the ground like
you didn't want to be the kid on the end
no no and then I remember we had this
guy uh Stevie lived down the street he
had Down syndrome and we would make him
chase us and we'd go in
go in the back door of my house and we'd
run out the front door of my house and
we'd stand in the driveway and just
watch him run back and forth in my house
like that was good time it was a good
time what's like tomorrow's July 4th
good times like our kids don't know July
4th and then stand very still yeah it
doesn't see it he used to pick us up by
her balls you're so strong right I think
that's amazing it's like scarring look I
think it'll fit my erection
for the rest of my life because like I
mean it was like many times a year he'd
come home from like his schooling he
went to school like somewhere else right
and when he was home he knew how to
whistle really good
and he would whistle like and we would
hear it and we would [__] just like
hide like we'd run into the woods but he
would have gone up your nuts behind us
he was like the Terminator yeah and I
remember once we were under Todd pifer's
couch in his basement like his parents
had a bar with like leather couches and
there was like a a TV stand but it was
closed like you couldn't see in there
like it was closed so we go under the
couch and we went on it was like an elk
okay it was an elk couch and there was a
TV stand here or the coffee table but it
was closed here so we we crawled under
the couch and we went under where the TV
thing was the coffee table was like you
couldn't see us and I remember we're
just under there and we just hear
footsteps coming downstairs like he
lived down the [__] Street and he
walked inside Todd Piper's house went
into the basement and just reached in
and
drag this out by her dicks like ah and
then he just would go home was he older
than you guys yeah it sounds like Stevie
molested you guys yeah you maybe if I
didn't say his last name
that's a soul brother you know it was
weird
like my nuts hurt now literally like
talking about it on on in Denver there
was a uh an advertisement huge
advertisement that said it had um one
guy famous guy I can't remember and I
think the baseball player and then it
had a somebody with Down Syndrome
another baseball player and it said yes
and it said Down syndrome people have
have just as much a right to a job
and a good way of life and it's like
well I know oh yeah I'm not I'm not
saying what the [__] is saying who the
[__] is saying they don't man I don't
want to fly my advertisements I don't
flying my plane yeah you can serve the
pain yeah because I've been I've been
always I've been I've always railed
against them having any kind of dignity
and having like a right to it I don't
know anybody who's like you get rid of
these days we can't have them having
anything that's not a sexy Lobby no no
it's like all right yeah we agree but
why is it I still professional baseball
players yeah hold on are you saying you
want that Stevie kid to throw curveballs
right for the color is it next to the
office that's against slavery too is
that you guys have you guys share an
office you guys anti-slavery too people
have right to Freedom someone should
just take spray paint go no [__] yeah of
course man what a waste of money yeah I
I just it that kind of [__] drives me
[__] nuts
you know but back to the block parties
there's not many Blockbusters and also
July 4th when I was a kid my dad used to
take us to the fireworks like the tents
they put up you grab the basket put in
all those dope like black cats and m80s
Nike my kids have never launched a fire
you know I grew up overseas and I never
have anything to relate to when people
talk about their dreams
I didn't move here till I was 14. but
it's weird when people say remember we
had I didn't grow up on a block ever you
grew up here I was born in the
Philippines and then we moved to India
Calcutta and Bombay and then uh and then
Lebanon and then Pakistan then Lebanon
again
and we were stuck there for a while and
then we got evacuated to Greece and then
Saudi Arabia how did I know this about
14 years old I went to boarding school
that's why it's so weird my parents
stayed in Saudi Arabia and I had to go
away to boarding school when I was 14.
that's why I didn't connect with anybody
man you know this I thought it was a
serial killer oh dude in the eyes it'd
be a great serial killer I had to I had
to break uh I had to not get attached to
people
that's why I'm really don't why are you
doing this character of the guy that's
like almost a serial killer talking to
us right now I am normal I'm really
happy to be here blink
blink your [__] eyes creep creep
blink okay there you go so as a kid
though even when I was not a blank B's
timings off even when you were 14 never
no fireworks in New York nothing no
you've never seen a firework I
didn't grow up with TV I people don't
realize like what we had to do with TV
back then was they would do they would
tape the shows on video and then they
would send them we had betamax but you
grew up normal right with fireworks yeah
you know what I remember about the kid
is like it was just a high school
football field and we just walked over
we laid on a blanket now it's like you
gotta drive to [__] Malibu or like
high hills or Ohio and you guys like
parking good luck I know it's also
because the fires just so so many fire
that's why they made them all illegal
because all the right fires oh and
legality never entered in my mind it's
just a pain in the ass I set my my me my
brother was launching those uh smoke
bombs at each other I said our [__]
Bush on fire my dad was out there with a
hose and [__] it's all good baby you
know what they say as well
so dad put that fire get the coin where
the hell will put it out yeah nice call
back I love callbacks smother the flame
to hell we used to take the bottle
rockets and put them in the end of the
Wiffle ball bag because on the bottom of
the wiffle ball bat there was a little
hole Yeah so you just put them in there
and light them and you just hold the
Wiffle ball out and shoot at each other
right yeah see what I can't remember
Brock fights yeah yeah I didn't grow up
what's awesome about the great being
American is you grew up in a
neighborhood well we know around all the
kids
you had to grow up when I lived in
yeah or you grew up in a compound
it's kind of weird really like caviar
[__] you know would you grow up more
caviar Khan that was our that was our
chef's name come on I'll have more
caviar please
God so was your dad like in the CIA or
he's a banker you're not buying that
right Banker too smart for that what did
his dad was a banker yeah man where's my
camera no one's buying those he worked
in a bank asked me which one because
bank which bank is all over the one over
there
I had a spy on my podcast Pete Turner
he's got a podcast now the break it down
show with Pete Turner he talks about
spying and I said uh so like what's your
actual job title he goes I fill gaps
then like I got and then like I did like
the the soft play you know and then like
it was like 11 minutes go by I go so
like what's your job title that goes I
work in phonetic space
and then I got it and then finally I got
him the closest I got him was I watch
people that watch us
oh that's good too
but is he active like right now who
knows
me and Dove David I was just looking for
Special Forces guys and the one this one
woman she goes if you guys are really
into that she goes that guy those guys
over there and she points to this dude
she goes those guys do stuff they never
wear uniforms then they disappear and
come back and and that those are
probably the guys that you're you'd be
interested that's all she said and then
I go uh we ended up talking to them and
I go what do you do in the military and
he goes he goes this and that
that was so cool I don't my ego's too
big I can never give an answer like that
I'd be like ever I just sold out the
Comedy Works
almost spy you know I can probably get
you in anywhere if you want me to spying
somebody I'll do it I just did the other
day
a whole lot of buying stuff to me it was
you yeah that'd be squealing man so how
weird how long were you overseas like
what am I looking at 14 years of my life
no USO tour numb nuts oh tier two weeks
two years
between 11 days between 11 days and two
years I can't remember I think I think
I'm talking like a spy I think 11 days
I went from infinite to finite obviously
I know but is the USO tour still going
on I remember we were trying to do one
like eight years ago but are they still
like no it got too dangerous I wanted to
go back every year and they were like
it's too dangerous because after 2007
they tried we wanted to go to fobs the
forward operating basis they were like
no
if you're gonna do it do it right that's
what I found go to Ukraine [__]
somebody I was I was uh offered Ukraine
I was offered to go shoot recently yes
that was offered didn't I tell you this
no so some retired Special Forces
fellows are were going there and you
know I do that show best of where I go
down they said come to you Chris chose
this you do it's just a travel show on
YouTube myself
and uh yeah it only gets like I'm gonna
get a show on the channel guide no I
won't do it because it's too much travel
but but I they said to me they all got
together and they said look man we will
get you this is how they pitched it they
go we'll get you inside Ukraine you can
shoot and you'll get to talk to the real
Ukrainian people on what's going on and
you'll we'll get you anywhere you want
and I said I go I go I go so how do we
do this so here's what we do we fly in I
can't tell you where but it's going to
be either a place in Hungary or Poland
and then what we'll do is we'll take a
train for about nine hours and then
we'll take a car for about eight hours
and I was like
I'm just not doing that of course yeah
right because she said because the
problem is they have the Russians have
spies in those train stations so they
always but even if it was easy even it
was a direct flight to Ukraine you're
still not doing correct sir why are they
calling I'm doing a YouTube show yeah
why is that interesting that they that
you're a Target
because they saw this guy who was a
special versus guy saw my show my best
no no I know why you're interesting and
why you do a show but why would you
what's interesting about you to the
Russian government that they would buy
no no it would be the ukrainians so so
here's why because number one these guys
are getting these guys are independently
getting paid apparently to do things
like train the Ukrainian Special Forces
yeah but then the idea would be the
ukrainians would be very interested in
getting an American to give them a
sympathetic eye a sort of a sympathetic
view on what they go through and what's
really happening so that that that
influences the US government to keep it
gets it out there keep funding going so
what's the problem with that that's what
that was their motivation to get me to
come back
dying that way because it's really
dangerous Oh I thought it was like
kidnapping or something there could be
it could be that Russians get a hold of
me spot well yeah so the Russians have a
very a vested interest also in making
sure that if you're training the the
Ukrainian Special Forces the Russians
are going to kill you yes and those guys
are okay with that Wagner guy yeah that
guy so him in Germany
I've seen black Fridays that were more
effective than this guy's [__] cool I
know
we got to like the shopping plan they
got to the like shopping cart Row in the
parking lot and they just [__] her
out by the way by the way you're
talk with Putin
huh it's all good
no Dead on Arrival correct thank you
yeah and by the way he he they made a
deal with Belarus the president of
Belarus is in power because of Putin
Putin tells the president of Belarus to
do to jump he jumps so pregoian got in
over his skis when you do that with
Putin you [__] die screwed and also
it's already taken OverWatch I'll be
just you back to you go to Ukraine I
know we need uh uptick in views but that
ain't it that ain't it that ain't worth
it
Steve Gorman drummer for the black
screen the fighter and the more I'll
tell that story another time Brian's
gonna die you have to fill in for him
fighting the more you guys might try
more you guys are crying more fighter
tell me what were you gonna say Steve
Gorman from The Black Crows they did a
corporate show in like St Petersburg in
1993-94
it was like Martha Stewart was there
like Steve Jobs maybe some of the names
that I'm saying are but that Hill people
and they they got paid like each guy
walked with and they're like after the
show like let's go get a beer and they
went to a bar and they lasted two sips
of beer and black crows by the way at
the time were all six five
all of them are big tall guys oh really
oh yeah Steve Gorman's a big boy I mean
the guy was married to Kate Hudson yeah
and and they look like a biker guy like
they're cool guys be great for the
computer and uh they got like two sips
into their drinks and all like five six
seven guys would just I like we need to
go back to the hotel immediately like it
was like the [__] Wild West oh yeah
like right Putin it was nuts yes
there's Steve Gorman
but remember Louis C.K right when right
when the UK wore launched why are you
looking it up like I'm lying wait Steve
what if I was lying yourself
Steve wait so Black Crowes I thought
that it says
that's not true at all
wow that's just not true he's all their
massive five six bring them up bring
them up let me see some pictures yeah
look like so those guys are out in a bar
in Russia and they're like they're super
skinny though I could I could beat them
not Steve Steve's the guy I could beat
every one of those guys up at the same
time you could be pretty much anybody
but I mean come on look at those guys
they were all drug addicts who cares
good times
I love them but they don't look tough
but why would they be tough to musicians
they look like a biker gang and then I'm
just saying it's like they look like
they're right on the back of them
there's like seven of them in a bar and
two sips in you know what Brian you
wonder why I eat no I apologize but it's
true that they but it's true that Russia
back then was [__] dangerous but the
thing about Louis C.K what a badass he
is during right when the UK War started
he's supposed to do tours all over
Ukraine and Russia and as they're flying
there they get the call and like no you
gotta turn around Lucy case still wanted
to do it because I'm playing like hey we
still have hopes we're gonna touch down
and figure it out so you're on your way
he was on his way yeah I mean you're
over there you're over the North Pole
you've already circled committed he was
still down to do it and then like hey
man I'm just just double checking up
five six they're all six five you got
your no that's off my foot man
no he's done five six no it's off by
foot well look at my Wikipedia it says
I'm five six how tall are you 5 10. see
how tall I am what does it say about I
want to see Jay more five nine yeah and
I'm not five nine you're five ten though
so it's off by an inch dude that's I had
an assistant pepper it and make it go up
and I told her to say my dad was a rabbi
the way the way to settle this is to
just just look at each other's dicks we
can't yeah we have get one 70 inches
that's about right I'm 70 inches tall
what's it say for me I'll be over you're
70 inches you're not five eleven I'm
actually taller than five eleven look at
that well I'll just I'm gonna take my
shoes off Morgan front headlock six four
look ranks that's about right look at
how different your face look dude look
at that [__] oh my God you look like you
work at Wells Fargo in Glendale
Men's Warehouse
your nose was so different you had to
get smashed into pieces you're gonna
love the way you look
you're gonna love the one you look
what are my parents names gotta be on my
Wikipedia page
like why do I gotta know your mom yeah
oh his mom is Deborah shop oh okay yeah
no Deborah Deborah man are your parents
still alive Brian
83 and 82. great
I remember when my mom died and I had to
fly home for the funeral and I get back
everybody goes how was the funeral I'm
like well
DJ was great good food but I'm not a
Coke guy so I left early how's the
[__] feeling all the sand yeah
so sad everybody asked how was the
funeral they all asked it this was when
who died you're my mom your mom yeah
yeah Alzheimer's that's fine that's epic
who were you again I'm JJ I'm your son
who's that man in the kitchen for us
John that's right only two years we got
lucky
my father my father
um my sister got so mad at my dad
because he's just eating like he's just
[__] eating anything he's a pig and
he's just eating like this like [__]
love George stuff that doesn't work and
he goes my my sister goes if your heart
could jump out of your chest it would
slap you in the face right now you see
like that cheesy scalloped potatoes or
some [__] he doesn't give a [__] I like
that he'll eat all my food respect you
look like Anthony Quinn sometimes I know
people tell you that yep who's Anthony
Quinn
he's got a YouTube channel Anthony Quinn
he's got a great actor he's got a great
YouTuber he's a great actress oh it does
look like Brian a little bit my dad
really looks like him man did he Quinn
I'm talking
about oh where was he from oh my God
what was he from no remember I'm not 60.
sorry about the Greek I mean he was
amazing no but he did some legit movie
star like a huge movie star
he did something recently he died in
2001. what were his parents names
look at him look up yeah I'll keep going
down like no this is like right before
he dies maybe God is what I'm thinking
of you got to go like the 60s yeah you
do he was he crushed on Hercules huh
great movie star Last Action Hero no no
no go go seriously go to like the 50s
the 50s yeah like Zorba the Greek
there you go right around there all
right yeah look Zorba the Greek
Lawrence of Arabia you know Requiem wage
dude The Savage innocence get out of
here these are huge movies
in 1959 man yeah
it was so easy to be famous then to be a
comic oh my god you watch like old like
I'm so bad you watch like Flip Wilson on
The Tonight Show he tells one joke
smoking a cigarette like do you want a
banana for your monkey good night
everybody yeah it's like what I know
this is [__] garbage no I know
of Jerry Seinfeld what he did Johnny uh
of course Carson and five minutes said
and it changed his whole career oh yeah
you know the difference between Paul
Reiser and Jerry Seinfeld no who are
these people who are these people
that's it so the emphasis on the word
who are these people who are these
people
Roger's like who I don't know who are
these people did you call the guy you
know what they say who's they who's the
guy
who's they who's like who won these
people
yeah well no there's a music to it
I like when you guys get quiet I know I
hit a vein in there yeah as we both just
you know hold on I'm staring at the
Google home page right now listeners so
this is terrible obviously but the kid's
okay not injured I love this but he felt
40 feet down a zip line are you [__]
kidding no no
in Mexico yeah so I'll show you the
video zipline Mexico is beyond me I
think this is his family filming it and
they didn't realize all I give a [__]
about are snakes I don't trust them
snakes is my only no non-starter
six-year-old kid
maybe the instructor
one of the ass crack in the instructor
that guy's hot I don't like this one of
the ropes was really right
but what happened to him chin he's not
injured damn he's just like this this
scares me so it falls into a lake so I
should say that all the way so obviously
they scream right here because
it's fell into the lake his parents are
the ones that didn't want to take it to
the hospital the people that worked at
the park they said like the second
hospital but no they looked at his
injuries his parents were like no he's
fine God he found the water thanks yeah
in the lake but 40 feet so I don't know
that's still damaging right yeah and
he's a six-year-old kid but he's fine
he's fine yeah as far as I guess the
parents say scroll up let me see the
article under it real quick
right there
he was taken out of the water by
Expedition on Amazon
before the black cayman got to him well
the harnesses that burst well he's got
to be black Brian that's why I don't
mean the black cayman black came in
that's a type of crocodile Fundy Dora
Park
not exactly the Dells in Wisconsin you
know what I mean harnesses had burst
what is it what is it made of balloons
it's just like what six-year-old doing
the whole show going on a zip line like
that I did it with my kid I would never
I wouldn't back in the day like 1990 I
was playing Tulane University opening
for Kennison and I was like well there's
nothing to do so I I bungee jumped but
there was no pad it was just straight to
the parking lot hell no you know that
swing when you do over the canyon yeah
yeah [__] you dude right I don't
understand any of that if I but like if
you guys did it I would totally like I'm
one of those guys like I'm not gonna
Skydive but if you're like bro we're
Skies we're like come on bro let's go
I'm not a [__] [__] you know what
when I went we went ziplining in rehab
the second rehab I went to and it's like
just that first step is such a mind like
I felt like Jackie Gleason like all I do
is step off step off the platform huh no
but then but then when you do it the
more and there's no way to get down and
there's no way to leave other than
finishing the seven consecutive zip
lines that get higher and higher and the
only way I got to the point where I was
okay with it was like I pretended I was
in the Army and I just had to do it yeah
and I was like all right I had to repel
off a cliff to get down yeah [__] that I
but when you're on on there and you're
leaning back and you have to just jump
on the rope and I just like terrifies
you you're just like and then you can
figure it out no my son has such a good
sense of humor my son's 11. we're in the
elevator with my whole family and I go I
think this is a good time to tell you
I'm not your father and you typically
think okay oh and I said I go I think
this is a good time to tell you that I'm
not your father he goes yeah
[Laughter]
my son came home the other day at dog
[__] on the edge of his hand
[Applause]
my son's allowed to swear when he's with
me he's 11. it's our thing so he gets in
the car his mom's like bye she gets so
mad at me he's like bye the door closes
and he goes when are you gonna clean
this [__]
I go you didn't do your homework he goes
nah I go why not he goes because I don't
give a [__] and I go see my face see my
face I did that I did exactly that and
he goes hold on before you get mad don't
get mad let me check the console of your
car
oh no [__] in there either
it sounds like a jerk yeah this kid
sounds like you might have some problems
I struck him about the face and ears I
said you're gonna go talk to all about
you're gonna you're gonna go talk to
Uncle Uncle Jay
all right with the Beast he's a big boy
he was so big he's 200 pounds how old is
he yeah level four 12 years old he's
four where's he get his size oh in food
there's hands all he eats is beige
steroids everything he eats is grilled
cheese and Fries just but he's just big
boned though too big body big he's a big
boy he's 12 in what grade six and then
what's he do do you play sports baseball
I remember I used to bring in the
wrestling practice when I was coaching
and he would just like Bam Bam everybody
he would just go through all
the workout yeah like he thought it was
fun but I was like you know what think
about it when you're a kid what do you
love to do you like to roll around yeah
you like to crash in and [__] yep and
you like to grab ass with your buddies
everybody built like that it's like all
right
my mom told me I was a gentle kid
I always thought I was they're totally
different she goes no you were
incredibly gentle and didn't like you
know my mom told me we're standing there
I know we're standing in the kitchen
once before dinner and my mom goes let
me see your hands I'm so glad you have
Ferguson hands your father has such
[__] hands
and they're like oh dinner's ready and I
sat right next to my dad and his little
milky white hand just sitting on it on
the tablecloth well it's like you know
I'm just staring at my dad's hands
there's a book called The pugilist at
rest and this woman is talking about how
she's in love with this she's married to
a you know a lawyer and he pays all the
bills but she [__] this guy who he's a
pearl diver bank robber right there just
that no he's our kind of guy yeah it's
just a uh just a big Italian
no but he's a really different criminal
and she goes and she's like she's
talking about how he how this her lover
just she's got these [__] huge hands
and she's looking at her husband as he's
buttering his toast in his suit and tie
and he's and he's got little things and
she despises of course she's like I can
never have those hands on me again and
all she's thinking about is as her just
[__] little Italian sausage Anthony
Quinn had big hands yes he did does he I
don't know yeah I believe he's a massive
hands he had baby hands
[Laughter]
they want to know if push comes to shove
can you fight your way out of this
situation yeah I think so I've only felt
I couldn't one time and I'm not like a
fight guy
but I know like if [__] hits the fan
like you know you know wrestling keep
them a little busy you know what I mean
I just don't yeah I don't want to come
across that guy but I remember the only
time I felt like completely helpless was
at the Super Bowl in Jacksonville
it was such a [__] show the they ran out
of food before kickoff
and it was it's not like a good stadium
Jacksonville I think it was the Eagles
and the Patriots and uh like the seats
were wood and I remember there was the
toilets that overflowed just before
kickoff so there was like a little
stream of water running through the
Concourse and just Eagles fans [__]
at one point a wheelchair ran over my
wife's foot and she said your
wheelchair's on she goes your
wheelchair's on my foot and she goes in
a minute
she had to finish up what she was saying
and it was me and Barry Katz and our
wives and I remember thinking if wow I
am truly alone versus the Eagles fans
who threw snowballs at Michael Irvin on
a stretch that's right and Santa Claus
hilarious yeah he thought he broke his
neck too and they were like they're like
good it was just like they booed him
they booed Santa Claus dude yeah
snowballs out yeah you ever met Michael
Urban yeah the big boy one of the best
people in the 20. he's great yeah one of
my favorite people I've ever met great
guy I agree yeah that era of guys are
all
you know he's the life of the party like
he he could have been a [__]
entertain everyone dude he's a life of
the party and he sees me and goes shut
up get off here baby I'm like oh what's
up baby you know there's all these
people and I go to drive turkey yeah
he's like what's up baby I'm like what's
up man I go to grab his hand he grabs my
head
holds me down and kisses the top of my
head in front of everybody that's
awesome it's so embarrassing that he
whispered how do you know him dick uh we
did the the tournament together the
charity tournament together and we are
Partners on the Bowling Tournament he's
such a good guy golf yeah he's such a
good guy your golfer nah
no no I'll play a little bit but and
he's Hall of Famer right yeah yeah
you're really not a sports guy at all
[__] man him Dion Sanders I spent uh a
whole week he's pretty good too yeah I
had so much fun with those guys
and I and I I go um what do you weigh
because he was always so small in on the
field and he goes not small he goes I'm
219. and I went huge two nights massive
I know I go no fat I was like that's
that's a small football player well it's
like there's not a small no he's not no
for a cornerback he's he's the best to
ever do it bro I had a really just got
his foot amputated yeah I know where's
his toes and he played in the World
Series in the Super Bowl in the same
time his foot they had to go back in
yeah so you saw the footstory they took
his stove now they dim to his foot no
that's what his girlfriend came out yeah
why what happened I'm not sure age he
just runs too fast no no no
it burnt the bottom of his feet it was a
gangrenous infection
he played in the Super Bowl in the World
Series in the same year yeah how about
that you know he used to play in
baseball games then fly same day and
play football games yeah
so not Brian Jordan did both too and
they were on the same team yep and then
I asked Wayne Corbett once the hardest
he ever got hit in football wide
receiver for the job and he goes Brian
Jordan knocked me the [__] out I was out
for like 15 20 minutes I remember that
there was an interception
against the Falcons and he relaxed and
Brian Jordan just came just saw the five
nine white guy went
supper yeah
retire because of concussions yeah he
woke up on the bench on the sideline
pre-like tent he's just laying on a
[__] bed so just getting laid out I
feel like it'll be all right so when he
was playing
when he wakes up they go do you know
where you are and he goes Willowbrook
Mall when did they put this in I mean
the Georgian home
when they put this in when they put when
they put a dome in everybody played or
some of the cameras together
I never missed a football game he's
great
I had DirecTV so I could watch like the
red zone of him and Keyshawn I never
watched I never really yeah
[Music]
that one I kind of sold but he's on the
radio show so what they're not going to
simulcast the radio show no hope I have
to go somewhere
my ex-girlfriend broke up with me and
started dating Keyshawn and would tell
me about it just because she was mad at
me that was good
it's got to be I can't believe it I
don't understand like the simulcast of
radio I'm just gonna pretend I didn't
hear that uh what did she say though she
she's like I'm into giant black guys
you're a small white guy she's pretty
black and white I'm following him home
right now in his car just wanted you to
let you know that
so you know why she did that because
they always push back on the parent they
know isn't going anywhere and deep in
her bones she knows that he's daddy
otherwise she wouldn't give a [__]
otherwise she wouldn't do this look at
my eyes she wouldn't give a [__] you
know what she knows Brian [__] made
her make those sounds that nobody ever
heard her make before and she also but
she'll surprise you I'll surprise you
well yeah sure he's all reliable here
but she also knows Keyshawn not him for
the Long Haul right so one-time ride
yeah no they got married
yeah they got three kids with Larissa
Pippin and I've never been up
and I've never been under any Illusions
the problem I had a weird like today
like this weekend because of Derek wolf
and and Brian Shaw I woke up the next
day after spending time with the
strongest man in the world four-time
strongest man in the world and then
Derek Wolfe who's a freak athlete and a
giant and also very handsome and I I was
like I looked at the pictures and I go
like this I go I need to uh yeah there
you go and I go I looked that picture
and I go I need to start lifting weights
more why are your arms bigger than your
torso I know I know I go yeah exactly I
go I gotta stop with it it's like so big
look at how big he is you look like
David Faustino uh yeah I do
yeah I do go keep going
Are you standing I'm doing that on
purpose I'm trying to stick my chest out
God damn he's a big boy yeah he's uh but
let me ask you a question yeah but can
he kick my ass well that's a good point
well so Lavon Lavon the best arm
wrestler they said he's they say he's
unbeatable from Ukraine's 400 pounds
Lavon said Brian's like I kind of want
to get into arm wrestling now after this
because it'd be easier instead of this
training natural transition levonne
Devon is like made a video so I'm joking
around goes Brian you don't need to get
enormous like just stay over there you
don't have to do this why are you
wearing that like Heath Morrison wig on
that one clip yes don't ask
how great is Keith Morrison the best
from Dateline when he's like the Dr
Seuss of murder
I was playing Greg Abbott the governor
of oh yeah for a sketch I look on
Dateline when Keith Morrison goes in a
small town the hair almost goes
something was brewing at the waffle
house but it wasn't the coffee
what was brewing
murder yeah what was this Brian is the
first half he was watching himself he
was he couldn't distract him I know yeah
narcissist I look at myself not but I'm
looking for something to change or I'm
disappointed I don't look at myself like
that I look good you're a hand there's a
couple of pictures I've said I look all
right most of the time
it's depressing
um how about the kid that goes can I pet
that dog
just look it up just look it up Tick
Tock or IG my sister's ass
Tim Tebow's virginity
areas on the left this one yeah yeah I
could listen to this kid all day
jump at that dog
[Music]
that's all he's cute
Kitty
[Music]
he just turns homeless at the end
seeing you go to sleep no I don't
anybody I'm gonna say it anybody who
doesn't have kids doesn't know what
they're missing
you got kids
these guys yeah man oh you said that
earlier you looked at me like over the
line or something you know come on man
[__] trying to keep that dog I'm just
trying to keep the show afloat
which is tough
is it yeah it's tough Brian how many
kids you got uh three who's your
favorite just say it
just say it
Brian has a favorite that's like loud
[__] you don't have a favorite there's
like one kid one kid's sweeter than the
others you know it just it depends day
by day man hey look there's not enough
oxygen on the sub for all three of us
I love all my children it's not enough
oxygen man I love my children for
different reasons I got a baby he's just
like a [__] just so he's going home
baby it's like raising myself and then
my daughter is just her own magical it's
your son [__] himself it's the sun
that's like you yeah you're a narcissist
how could you say this about it my
daughter my daughter is like I don't
know it's my first born so I you know
all right so you're killing your son I
love them all you got two sons then yeah
so one can go no I can't I could bro
we're all gonna die on this [__] sub
somebody's got to go your favorite yeah
you do of course I do yeah I understand
of course I did
and you have how many two
that I know of
what do you got I think I think that I
think that there's no doubt that most
parents probably would have behind
closed doors would be like I mean
there's one like every time they cry as
a kid you're like this [__] guy well
some kids are more difficult than others
you know some kids are just like yeah my
brother was super difficult I know for a
fact you asked my parents when we were
like 12 they're like oh Brent we'll kill
easier yeah bread was easy yeah
my son when he was like five years old
told me to suck his dick on Christmas
morning
just that I know it was the first
Christmas after the divorce so we're
staying together like just giving the
illusion of one big happy family hers
because mine's still in New Jersey yeah
so her whole family's in my house eating
[__] shrimp and this and my son opens
up a Nerf gun he's like whoa Nerf Gun
Daddy suck my dick
I'm like what and they're all looking at
me there's like a custody battle going
on they're looking at me like we could
use this but
I'm not looking back I'm just looking at
my son trying to use telepathy like what
the [__] and he's like Daddy suck my
dick
bury me I go I got a bigger Nerf gun
I got one upstairs you want to see it
he's like oh suck my dick so we go up to
his bedroom I go do you know what she
said down there and he's like no Nerf
gun I'm like do you remember what else
you said he goes I do not no you
remember saying suck my dick he's like
because you know what that means he goes
no
hang on that's like
that's what a Dick's like what a a dumb
guy calls his penis you know and you're
a real smart guy
and uh so in front of the whole family
you said you wanted your penis in my
mouth and you wanted me to suck it this
is when I knew I had a favorite kid
my son's reaction goes
subscribe
then Easter starts laughing then I start
laughing then we start wrestling then I
throw him on the bunk beds which break
and if you're downstairs it sounds
exactly like we went upstairs to suck
each other's dicks
my son uh went after I never kind of
like
did a check-in after I got divorced and
I'm a dinner
hold on hold on a what a check in on
your account how you guys doing with
this you know like you didn't talk about
their feelings like not enough yeah man
that's a big deal yeah you guys are fine
my son's eating like that and I go hey
you know we haven't talked about how you
guys are doing you know this is a big
thing again it was like three years ago
he goes my son goes he goes I'm all
right
can't be good
my daughter goes all my friends parents
have gotten divorced relax like that
that was the end of the discussion I was
like how old was he then [__] eight
because she's still wearing a diaper
it's fine I'm all right I'm all right no
problem supporting Wonder Pets diapers
you know peanut butter all those [__]
face
I'm fine
okay so much for that talk I remember
when I was like when when you gotta
bring up the divorce it's like so you
got a big boy decision to make you know
it's about where you're going to live
mostly you know it's I don't want to
sway your decision it's either you could
either live with you know
son
foreign
but no big deal it's a big how long ago
did you get divorced
man almost five years ago it's me too I
get along great with Max at the time
it's it was the most profound
wound in my soul
yeah
[__] because nobody gets married to get
divorced you get married because you're
positive it's not a possibility yeah
that's why you do it and you walk around
for like it's not even the divorce
people go like I'm really sorry about
your divorce it's like oh no now that
it's underway I'm great I wish you could
have said sorry the two years I walked
around my own house going what the [__]
is going on am I gonna get out of this
yeah God damn I was here I'm the only
one in my entire extended family who's
been divorced but I don't come from
divorce well Saudis you know yeah how
many of them beheaded yeah well the
stone I'm not I'm not Saudi what a great
way to kill somebody [__] my stone it
takes a lot of hatred it takes a while
yeah
the eye again okay you missed ah that
biblical [__] is awful the worst
adultery but divorce in fact I come from
divorce family America was traumatizing
for as a kid
what it's wrong it was your fault that's
the worst thing yeah and it wasn't oh
well it was your fault it's the worst
thing you do kid but me my worst thing
you can do is stay together I get so
much credit to my ex though because she
was like we both decided we're gonna put
the kids to First no messy divorce no
nothing man and so that we get along
they see we talk we we hang it's it is
what it is there's no right way to do it
I mean it's a disaster it still sucks
yeah because my I heard my thought my
son say he was talking to somebody he
goes yeah my dad doesn't live at home
anymore
and it was he was bummed about it oh
that killed me
that killed me yeah you know hey you you
live I remember in mediation the
sticking point was this thing called the
Smith Osler agreement oh I know about it
what's that it's like okay this is what
you make now this this these last three
calendar years we know what you make and
it's just a grid it's just this is now
this is what she's gonna make the Smith
Osler is if you go above that number
then she gets more money right but at
the time I was doing radio I didn't have
I was doing well but not like not like
you guys Jesus no and uh I was like no
absolutely not and my lawyers are like
what we're like we're out of here what
are you doing I go no it's like a really
weird like put my foot down and I
remember the mediator goes
why I've never had somebody like this
adamant about a Smith Osler agreement I
go well
I just did the Turning Stone Casino in
Syracuse I woke up at four in the
morning
to get a 6 a.m flight
I had to lay over in Chicago I got to my
hotel room in Syracuse at 6 40 pm
my show is at seven
I performed for an hour and a half went
back to my room got four hours of sleep
because I had to get back on the plane
at 6 a.m and come all the way back now
if I'm willing to do all that for twenty
thousand dollars why the [__] should she
get a piece of that that and she goes
like they're sitting over here I
remember she just goes
like a really no the mediator just goes
like I just it was one of those moments
where I explained I explained it even
better than that yeah but I remember
like I would have flown to Hamburg in
the time it took me yes to get to
[__] sister that's the part that kind
of kills you in January and did they
what did they say about it was your wife
like I understand that or no it worked
out it worked out we get along well
that's that's so important because I I
know people that just lose their their
health over the fact that they're
fighting and I and I want to take care
of my dad got diabetes when he got
divorced I'm sure it's probably the
sugar is horrible well that was like the
final no that's stressful it was the
stress tax your adrenals yeah but uh I
was at the height of my my uh earning
power I was making more money than I
ever earned in my life at one point for
those three years that's when you got
some rice I've ever seen dude the guy
got it and I can begin what happened
after that yeah but yours was so bad you
guys got weak constitutions oh I was uh
I aged uh these past three allergic to
milk Brian's age like a president since
the yeah okay Lincoln yeah literally I
saw George Washington three years ago I
had totally dark hair three years my
hair was almost dark I'm gray as [__]
now but you can throw some dick I can
still throw dicks I never missed a
[__] thing I never missed a workout
oh I throw [__] grapevines at him so
fast
yeah oh I love riding legs
here's the thing is like you want to
take care of them that's it for me it's
like I said first thing I wear mediation
at my my ex I looked at the lawyers I go
the most important people right now are
the mother of my children my children
like I'll live in a [__] van by the
river right so we got to figure out how
that is I'm not interested in this
lawyer back and forth [__] and that was
that was a great way to start off
because who knows how much it's you want
to take care of them but also I don't
want to get completely [__] man like
we both think it sucks you're going to
you didn't get [__] no matter what
okay I have two Ex-Wives that own houses
and I rent that's me too it's like but
not 2x at one point my time
like you guys weren't writing jokes you
weren't up to four in the morning
writing on Saturday Night Live the [__]
did you attorney
uh yeah and I don't get any of my
residuals
at one point my child support was ten
thousand dollars a month
so I go out I remember I was doing the
Tempe Improv and I was like I'll
probably make about 35 right for the
weekend big room
yeah Debbie's big my rent in Malibu was
seven
because I was on the water so at one
point it's like first of all after 35
after taxes and commission 20. well
that's the point of what I'm about to
say yeah yeah you beat them to it man
but he's right I owed I basically got on
the plane I got back in my car owing
1800 yeah that's what people don't
realize it's [__] insane so so off
the top 10 so now I'm at 25 let's say
30. so off the top 10 that's 20. my
rent's seven I got 13. my agent gets
three I'm at 10. I'm paying 44 taxes on
the 30.
it's [__] crazy
that's why it's good to just get out of
Show Business
is it though and then you work at nine
to five good luck making 20 grand in a
week in there yeah just [__] relax
yeah give it to God it'll happen for you
thank you
you know what the worst thing you can do
in my opinion I will figure it out the
universal provide mm-hmm no well no you
got to make plans you guys are making
like money
like I never made it I have 100 million
dollars in the bank
but that's from when you lived in Saudi
Arabia yes that's because I'm in I own
oil fields I never like I never had like
ads like back in the day on my podcast
it was like a 60 40 split to talk about
Squatty Potty
and it was like the most I made was like
a thousand a week and I'm like this I
just would rather not have ads then I
get out and you guys come in and
everybody's just you got your own
Studios and Calabasas you're doing well
Theo you everybody Rogan's forget it oh
Robin yeah but I can't but I can't get
back into it because it would be an
admission to myself I'm getting back in
for the money and I can't operate that
way no see I think you should get back
in it because you love doing it really
good no I don't love doing it obviously
I don't really care yeah because people
like when are you gonna do it
yeah that's a big part all my money's
tied up in property though well that's
that's good no a [__] divorce twice
twice yeah I thought just once oh wait
before Nikki or after yeah another one
so before Nikki were married yeah
two boys one with each oh are you still
paying uh I still owe her yeah because I
wasn't able to pay because I was in
rehab and covid not a big comedy market
during a pandemic right let me ask you a
question
this is where I'm like when you were
talking about politics earlier I just
tapped out completely because I just
it's exactly it just doesn't [__]
matter it doesn't we're a trillion
dollars in debt we all agree that's a
fact right yeah the country
so the pandemic happens no businesses
are open
there's no Commerce there's no supply
and demand
there's no landlord that receives any
rent
there's no utilities there's nothing
but then the government a trillion
dollars in debt Cuts every American a
check for fifteen hundred dollars that's
when I went you [__] yeah
something is of shell game or they send
Ukraine two trillion well no they're
printing money right well that's like
credit card debt yeah you just pay a
little off here there but the fact that
you're going to send me a [__] check
that I'm gonna cash it like wait I
thought we were a trillion dollars in
debt remember you're a kid they go hey
we're cutting down the rainforest the
size of Great Britain gets disappeared
every year I remember in fifth grade I
remember clearer's Day by the by the
year 2000 there'll be no more rainforest
yeah I remember that you watch Like An
Inconvenient Truth Al Gore the Paul the
ice and by the way they are taking it
away I know that and I know the ice caps
are melting I know there is climate
change and global warming and I I know
that's all true but it's like that Al
Gore [__] was totally off though yeah
but all of it's off everything they ever
told me as a kid the whole news the
whole in the ozone layer was gonna open
a dinosaur fossil you know like I never
then you talk to like a spy or a CIA guy
and they go you go what's the actual
problem and they dropped some [__] on
you like running out of water yeah and
you're like what what water we need
water
it's like yeah so I mean there's not an
infinite supply of water on a floating
Rock eventually we're going to be done
with water there are weird things like
that like that super volcano that's
underneath Yellowstone yeah if that
thing blows we're all done we're all
gone and that's a chance
you gotta have a roll bar I didn't have
one in my must I remember I was on my
Mustang in like 1994 I'm on the 101
South and these two vatos pull up next
to me in like a convertible [__]
massive car yeah and they're like this
like God I'm like this is a little
uncomfortable like I don't want to race
these guys they're probably going to
want to fight me whatever and then so I
just hit the engine and I go and they
start chasing me and I watch in my
rearview mirror as their car I don't
know what happened it caught air under
it or something and it just went back
and flipped over and I was like
I don't know not my business back there
my business but I never saw a car they
died I just never saw a cargo like this
maybe that's like Hydraulics or
something it's like they hit the brake
line in the ocean Jesus I want to be do
you feel like you're I'm not prepped
enough for the zombie apocalypse
I need a little bit like the volcano
comes okay
I need I need something though man to do
what what are you gonna do there's no
amount of prep that's gonna save you
from like a Pompeii situation yeah yeah
because you know back in the day in
Pompeii there's those [__]
that like collected beads and [__] and
like I got my bug out back in case that
[__] thing blows in case Edna goes
I'm all right yeah and they're just
[__] they didn't realize they didn't
realize how fast
seismic event and then all of a sudden
order breaks down and then it becomes
The Purge I want to be ready for that
you will be ready we're more closer to
Civil War than anything like that Civil
War that'd be terrifying I'd be picking
[__] off of my roof oh yeah
yeah
nobody wins in that situation because
very evil people on both sides just take
over and have their militias I've been
hoarding antibiotics since 2002.
antibiotics is Ever Clear
I mean you can sell ammo the singer can
sell alcohol that you can drink and use
as a cleaner
you know if you murder somebody and you
clean them up in the tub
make sure you bleach underneath
the drain that's how most of you guys
get caught oh you got a bleach
underneath the drain yeah because they
just unscrew and they look at it because
when the blood goes down it kind of
splashes around under there
wait but now they test for bleach
my tub whenever I want doesn't make me a
murderer wait in the drain you have to
see if the water drains out yeah when it
goes down the drain yeah there's still
blood people forget is there's going to
be blood under
if you drink a bottle of water there's
going to be water on the bottle cap on
the inside
[__] I gotta do that
stop using credit cards get the rope
with the wax on it is that what I got to
do what one how do you know so much
Dateline the details it's always a white
lady on Dateline
that won't stop running their [__]
mouth
yeah she always gets killed by her
husband she's always named Patty
it's always a way lady named Patty but I
talked to a guy who does cold cases and
I was trying to I've said to him let me
try to get out of the way with a murder
you can't get away if he goes if we want
to get you and we actually put our
resources there I go okay so I shoot I
shoot you from
700 yards away outside when you're
hiking and he goes we get you and I go
how would your dad he goes we take dogs
we look at the we look at the ballistics
we can tell you got shot from a distance
we know what kind of bullet it is we
take we take a dog we start circling
circling circling we'll find where you
were lying I'll collect all those leaves
every one of those leaves in the whole
area take it back to the lab find
yourself but you know how to say that
guy you know what the other guy then why
are 53 percent of murders unsolved he
said I asked Brian would get caught
because it'd be bite marks on all the
leaves yeah
these are so good for you bro I don't
know I'm into organic these are so good
for you throwing [__] there with a with
a flag Brian was here well you can't do
that when you're there when you're
killing him yes 53 that's how I leave my
Mark I can't leave myself three percent
of mergers unsolved Brian why are you
doing calisthenics outside the car
run a Stakeout he's doing [__] squat
thrusts next to the car like let me just
get your sweats everywhere let me just
get this yeah you leave your cells did
you jack off at one boy yeah it really
like and and also
they if they want you for it they build
a case toward that as opposed to taking
in all the evidence and building the
case that way they've taken a suspect
and they funnel all the evidence that
way also even so that's why it's
everywhere there are roadside cameras
you just they can find point of entry
self-defense like what were you doing in
that car all that stuff
don't you think you could pass a lie
detector test I don't know I mean you
don't have a nature you have what I I
have we did a lot and I was telling the
truth about everything and they said I
was a liar I said did you arrest my high
school I was like yeah you're lying
because I was squirmy
I feel like I could be I've had guys in
the FBI who are like you can't beat it
well that's why they stop using them
though because they didn't hold up in
the court of law well you can't they're
not they use them but they're not
admissible
but I took it like if you go like is
your name Jay Moore I'm thinking my my
well my birth name is John I go by JJ so
already the [__] needle's going like
you know OJ Simpson took one uh his
lawyers right before they right when
they got one before it got big let's do
a lie detector test and because if in
there they go you're innocent yeah I
promise you all right let's do a lie
detector test because even though it
won't work in the court law we can bring
it up let him take the logic testing
failed miserably they're like oh guys
you know why I like uh wrestling and
Jujitsu more than karate Ron Goldman
second degree Blackwell
Ron gold the guy OJ [__] stabbed it
as oh he was the secondary he goes to
land a [__] kick he slips in blood
game over
yeah well uh also that's close to me to
stab me yeah it doesn't work yeah
allegedly against an NFL football player
with a large knife your karate is no
good here I don't think Crown is good
anyway
she's not practical if you if you have
to get in a stance you don't have to
fight what was your black belt then it
said third degree black belt yeah yeah
but yeah that's correct third degree
I don't know he was on studs I wish he
lived
it's such a bummer
you know hosted studs
what wasn't it
I don't know I'm asking if you knew
I'll let you know
host it's Mark DeCarlo yep yeah that was
his name yep
Yvonne De Carlo was his uh mom
oh I kind of remember this guy
can I bet that down
how about that dog
I remember that guy yeah all right you
didn't get any more for us
is he good or what do you want give us
one more good one
um so this because he's in front of the
show
adam22 he's in front of yours so I guess
his girl she did start porn in the
beginning but then once they got
together
so his wife
Lana or Lana the place you know I think
Lena the plug she's a porn star they met
when she's porn star but since since
they got together she's beautiful but
since they got together she's only slept
with women and never with another man
she stopped doing like male female porn
and then recently he has a show called
the plug talk where they the interview
porn star and then they both [__] the
girl who watches that more or Brian
Cowan show oof close both do really well
but um recently she he was open to her
[__] a dude and they got if you've if
you watch black before he's like the
star of black that dude is awesome yeah
I know the real pie bottom too yeah his
name is Love yeah he's a Carl Malone a
porn star jacked out of his mind he's
got a piece alone he brings it every
come alone he delivers every time baby
oh he delivers everything but that's his
post uh it's kind of funny too it's
officially been a week since I let my
wife do porn with another guy I felt a
little jealous at first but over overall
wasn't a big deal she's watching me
sleep with hundreds of girls and never
affect our relationship sleeping with
that gentleman has been amazing for both
of her career and our business the plug
talk overall I'm glad we did it and I'm
happy to report her Regina has returned
to its original pre big black [__] size
so this is what he's tweeting about his
wife yeah and they have a kid they do
have a kid for real those two kids are
gonna approved
so the kid can go online and go oh my
mom go oh now I know why she's leaning
the plug yeah
Adam
YouTube 22. Yeah his show it might be no
chase or something no no jumper but but
but the the plug show is his biggest
show I think it has to be subscription
but look some people are into this stuff
and it's that's it I don't care if
that's what he likes to do I don't give
a [__] I don't want to do it okay and if
he's open to I don't care why people
care she's down he's down who gives a
[__]
I don't care
that's it
we're almost at two hours I love it so
you make it easy dude July 9th that is
July 9th I'm doing a show with Daryl
Hammond we're doing impressions
look how fat I was I'll come to that
you're only 52 you're a kid
I'm a lot older than you here we go oh
there's my intake photo from rehab where
it's on my page there you go is the ad
oh you'll see the boy
[Music]
Chris Penn boys
Christ
that looks crazy
yeah that's cool you want to see my
intake photo you guys have done shows
before together
you get to sit down
what's he up to besides that stand up go
back to my page let's just see what I
got going on
what about me you said intake photo or
yeah scroll down tell me one like keep
just wait out was it a wicked
look fighter and the kid all over that
[__] no keep going oh me as dick
vitals you ever see that no where where
right there I'll go to that
baby
[Music]
you get the point
oh keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep you'll
just see me bald looking [__]
terrified keep going keep going no
whammies no whammies no whammies no
whams past it pass it yeah no he passed
oh
no oh look at that me jumping rope bruh
there you go
feet are strange that's fine oh I got a
crazy crooked feet
uh
yeah keep getting your heart checked
there my heart's [__] what are you
talking about forget our Sonic right on
your heart
Sonic sound
right there which one with the hat on or
the oh wow
intake meaning you were going to rehab
that's like when they're yeah wow
after the Wu-Tang wow damn wait go back
to that you don't look bad no solace
were you doing at that point all of it
all of it all of it probably 300
milligrams a day yeah
300 what was your main thing was it
Adderall I wake up swallow of 30 snort a
30 take my kid to school snort 15 on the
way back swallow with 30.
I drive to Malibu to fish swallow a 30.
like that's we're not even at 9am yet
how the [__] did your heart not stop
okay
how did yours not stop start what
there was one well I bet those fish were
[__] when all that out or all just
[__] I fished alcoholically one year
we took a hundred fish out
just on the paddle boards fishing from
the paddle boards off right behind dukes
and like we're on there oh yeah wow what
kind of [__] fish calico bass oh damn
would you eat them yeah I was like a
[__] I I would do that I would
paddle to the Malibu pyramid back then
go run wrestling practice what would you
use for bait
uh no Rapala crankbaits they got like
the plastic things he knows what's up
yeah oh I'm a fisherman too yes
that's one of my favorite things yeah
but you're fishing carp you're Asian no
I'm not fisherman cart man you can't eat
carp it's disgusting yeah it's horrible
that's right the Grunion around and
there goes chin I know I don't go
grinding I should get together and
murder some things
crops suck they're too they're too bony
they're disgusting they give me the
creep and koi you go to somebody they
got those stupid lips yeah I like koi
you can bounce like corn niblet right on
this Nellis they're like yeah right but
those bass are voracious eaters dude
they love that [__] crankbait that
thing goes by they just [__] I had I
had this on a GoPro so I could prove it
I caught a baby barracuda I'm on the
paddle board and I'm filming it on a
GoPro and I get them to like where that
bottle is off the side of the paddle
board and a [__] bass comes up under
it and goes to eat the Barracuda and
hits the other part of the lore so I
brought in two fish on one
uh too many dolphin yeah I saw one once
I was behind dukes and it was like late
afternoon and it was just coming toward
me swimming North as you guys would know
it but it's actually West North and I
was like oh [__] and I was like it's not
a dolphin because the Tail's doing this
not this oh wow and so I paddled home
like as quickly and calmly as possible
but the sun was setting so every time I
turned around I looked the sun was I
couldn't [__] see and I got about a
quarter mile and I saw Dolphins over
here and I'm like okay thank God how big
was it I don't know I just became a
speck of dust yeah immediately like yeah
yeah it's fun see a lot of gray whales
do you really well they're either coming
or going they're either like it's like
March April like November I think it's
like November they come in that close
yeah November they come down
Brennan loves this
okay go check it out yourself behind
Dukes right on Dukes [__] go your
your own Sid but come on man I just want
to go see some whales with behind Dukes
man
tell you what guys if you like comedy
you come to the green zone you can tell
he's funny look at that one photo
Greenville yeah Greenville South
Carolina
the this Friday this Saturday and then
I'm at the Blue Room Springfield
Missouri
July 20 21 and 22. come get no actually
I'm only there 21 and 22. I got to take
that off the website all right you go on
the road a lot when's enough uh yeah
well when I'm around La July 28th job
and friends are you in town July 28th I
gotta check my day planner let me know
I'll text you I'm old school we got a
bunch of dates coming up love you guys
Jay Moore where you going today more at
the Hollywood improv like we said July
9th I got two months off man I'm
chilling yeah man I'm chilling too all
right kids love you